طبعا المروحيه سقطت هنا حتى الان سالت عدد
من الخبراء يعني في الموقع وقالوا انه غير
معلوم سبب سقوط هذه المروحيه حتى الان
جاري التحقيق في الامر جاري طبعا عمليه
رفع همم وجمع الادله
ول- اا لتوضيح يعني سبب هذا الحادث
المعلوم ان وزير الداخليه وانا ابي ووزيره
دوله كانوا في رحله عمل الى مواقع ساخنه
هكذا قال كريم شوكو همم نائب همم رئيس
ديوان الرئاسه الاوكراني قال ان همم الوفد
الوزاري كان في طريقه في رحله عمل الى
مناطق ساخنه في جبهات القتال ولكن حتى
الان نشاهد ايضا هذا الشخص احد المصابين
كما تشاهدين ايضا همم يعني الاسعاف يقوم
باسعافه
من موقع الحدث
وهنالك 29 مصابا اخرين في هذا الموقع هذا
المنطقه طبعا منطقه سكنيه اذا تابعتي معي
هذا هذا هذا هذا نعم هذا هذا حي سكني عادي
وهذا رياض اطفال في وسط الحيه السكني
والاطفال كانوا في رياض الاطفال لحظه حدوث
هذا الحادث وسقوط المروحيه الان الحديث
طبعا في الاوساط الاوكرانيه وفي الاعلام
الاوكراني عن تغيير طبيعه الدراسه طبعا
هنالك جد الكبير فاطمه حول هذا الامر في
الاوساط الاوكرانيه وسط الاهالي وسط في
الاعلام الاوكرانيه يتم تداول عمليه خطوره
ذهابها هؤلاء الاطفال الى الدراسه وكان في
المدارس او في الرياض على الاطفال همم
لذلك الان هذه الموضوع الان يتم تداوله من
جديد بعد هذه الحادثه انه من الخطوره
بمكان ان
يعني يذهب الاطفال يجب ان يدرسوا عن طريق
الدراسه عن بعدها كذا يعتقد يعني
المواطنين واولياء الامور انه يجب ان
تستمر الدراسه عن بعد طبعا القرار هو يعني
من منطقه لمنطقه يختلف هنالك من هم ما
زالوا يدرسون عن بعده هنالك من بداوا في
الدراسه بشكل طبيعي طبعا تعلمين ايضا وضع
الطاقه يؤثر كثيرا على همم طبيعه همم عمل
همم المدارس والرياض الاطفال همم ولكن
يعني بدا همم هذا الموضوع يسار مره اخرى
في الاوساط الاوكراني